في الاثناء نقلت عن دبلوماسيه غربيا رفيع
في طهران ان هناك زخما جديدا لامكانيه
تبادل اسرع بين ايران والولايات المتحده
واضافت الصحيفه عن مصدر مطلع ان المناقشات
لا تزال جاريه بشان الافراج عن الاموال
الايرانيه ولفتت الى ان بايدن قد يواجه رد
فعل عنيفا اذا سمحت ادارته بتحويل مليارات
الدولارات للنظام الايراني واستطردت
الصحيفه ان احد الخيارات هو الاحتفاظ بهذه
الاموال في حساب بقطر لضمان استخدامها
لشراء سلع غير خاضعه للعقوبات واشارت الى
ان قطر ساعدت في تسهيل محادثات بين ايران
والولايات المتحده في سبتمبر الماضي اثناء
اجتماعات الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
بشان تبادل محتمل للسجناء
في طهران ايضا وفي سياق اخر قال الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي خلال لقائه مع
نظيره البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو في
طهران ان بلديهما يعارضان ما وصفه
بالسياسات الاحاديه الجانب ويعمل معا
لمواجهه سياسه العقوبات بينما قال
لوكاشنكو خلال حفل توقيع اتفاقيات تعاون
اقتصادي مع ايران ان مواقف البلدين
متقاربه بشان التطورات الاقليميه والدوليه
وانهما يعملان على ايجاد عالم متعدد
الاقطاب على حد تعبيره
من طهران معنا من هناك مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين نور الدين قبل ان نخوض في هذا
اللقاء بين الرئيسين البيلاروسي والايراني
لنعود الى تفاعلات قضيه
وزير الخارجيه يتعلق بمساله تبادل السجناء
وما وصفته الخارجيه الايرانيه بانه موقف
مستغرب طبعا ردا على رد الفعل الامريكي
[موسيقى]
لا يتم الان العمل عليه هو تقريبا شبه
اتفاق ربما يحتاج فقط لمجموعه من
التعديلات وهذه التعديلات تتم عن طريق
تبادل الرسائل بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يبدو انها تفهم بان المساله هي
مساله الوصول الى اتفاق يتم التوقيع عليه
وفق المعطيات الجديده اذا ربما هناك
اختلاف في الفهم وفي المعنى ما بين
الجانبين لكن ما هو ثابت وما اجمع عليه
الطرفين سواء الجانب الامريكي او الجانب
الايراني على ان هناك مفاوضات غير مباشره
ما بينهما من اجل الوصول الى الصيغه وهناك
دول فاعله في هذا المجال ويتم بالتحديد
الحديد عن سلطنه عمان وعن دوله قطريه يبدو
ان الجانب المالي يرتبط بدوله قطر عبر
تسهيل المساله الماليه
ووقف الحجر على او تجميد الاموال الماليه
لدى الاموال الايرانيه المجمده خاصه في
كوريا الجنوبيه وبحث كيفيه استغلالها
كيفيه استغلالها عن طريق المصارف القطريه
وهناك يبدو انه السياسي المتواجد في سلطنه
عمان والمفاوضات في هذا الشق وما يدلل على
ذلك وهو وجود المساعد السياسي لوزير
الخارجيه لرانيا وكبيرا المفوضين
الايرانيين علي باقر الذي كان في سلطنه
عمان المهم في كل هذا ما يتم الحديث عنه
وما يتم تداوله ان هناك مفاوضات من اجل
اطلاق سراح السجناء هناك ثلاث سجناء
مزدوج الجنسيه الايرانيه الامريكيه
متواجدون هنا في طهران وهناك عدد من
السجناء الايرانيين المتهمين من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالالتفاف على
العمل على الالتفاف على العقوبات تقدر
الاحصاءات عددهم بحوالي 15 سجنا يبدو ان
كل هذا قد يدخل في صفقه لكن هل الصفقه
اصبحت ناضجه يبدو ان الامر غير ذلك وهو
نتاج هذا الخلاف في المواقع بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فيما يتعلق باللقاء بين
الرئيسين الايراني والبيلاروسي وهذا
الرسائل الواضحه الذهاب باتجاه عالم متعدد
الاقطاب
باختصار و تكرمت
بكل نعم بكل تاكيد عبد القادر هنا لابد من
الاشاره بعسله الى موضعين اساسيه لان
ايران اصبحت عضو في منظمه شونغهاي
وبلاروسيا عضو كذلك في منظمه كذلك
بيلاروسيا هي عضو في التجمع الاوراسي
وايران تسعى للتعاون مع هذا الجانب اذا في
هذا السياق ما يمكن الحديث عنه انه ما حدث
الطهران هو الدفع بالعمل الاقتصادي العمل
التجاري وهو ما تبين من اتفاقيات الموقعه
ما بين البلدين وكذلك اعاده احياء
العلاقات ما بين منسك وما بين طهران خاصه
ان هذه العلاقات عرفت نوعا من شهدت نوعا
من الجمود خلال 17 سنه الماضيه هذه
الزياره لرئيس البيلاروسي الى طهران هي
جزء من اعاده احياء هذه العلاقه الثنائيه
باستغلال التقاطع ما بين الجانبين سواء في
التعاون الاوراسي او التعاون على منظمه
وكذلك لتجاوز التحديات هنا نشير على ان
الازمنه الاوكرانيه تركب بالتحدياتها على
بيلاروسيا وعلى الطهران وبالتالي وجود
الرئيسين هنا في طهران قد يحاول شكله داخل
صياغه موقف ما في التعامل مع هذه الازمه
شكرا جزيلا لك